hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
und herzlich willkommen bei
[Musik]
ich stehe hier gerade bei unserem Team
im Büro und zwar im cellicon Valley oben
bei den Jungs und Mädels im Design
Grafik marketingbüro und hier oben haben
wir vor kurzem diese schöne
Landhausküche eingebaut
heute wird endlich unsere Küche
geliefert der große LKW von Nobilia ist
schon da und ich habe auch gesehen es
sind zwei Fahrer ich begrüße mal die
beiden mit Kaffee und Kuchen natürlich
hi ihr zwei einmal schwarz mit Zucker
und einmal mit Milch und Zucker
ja und Kuchen für euch
ja ich würde sagen der LKW nee die
Zugmaschine mit auflade Aufleger der
Aufleger wird jetzt ausgeladen und dann
können wir die Küche drin schon aufbauen
also nicht ich habe schon die Vorplanung
gemacht ich würde sagen das überlasse
ich den Männern den Mund hören die sind
nämlich auch gleich da
[Musik]
hallo hallo das sind Jörg und Sebastian
die beiden montieren jetzt hier die
Mitarbeiterküche richtig sehr gut und es
sieht auch alles sehr gut aus bis auf
die Wand die der Murat hat falsch
streichen lassen aber ist auch kein
Problem man kann ja mal grau-blau mit
beige verwechseln aber ist kein Problem
das Streichen wir einfach später nach
genau hier wird jetzt die Küche montiert
im Prinzip könnt euch am Küchenplan von
Samira orientieren gemalt und ich glaube
ja da könnt ihr euch dran orientieren
[Musik]
die Landhausküche ist muss ich sagen so
mein Favorit momentan was Küchen
betrifft weil ich einfach dieses Grün
sehr liebe das Design Liebe und ich
finde Landhaus muss er nicht immer
altbacken und klassisch sein Landhaus
kann ja auch wirklich ganz ganz neu
modern und richtig stylisch kombiniert
werden und deswegen werde ich jetzt hier
diese Küche einrichten das heißt alles
was hier in die Küche kommt wird hier
eben auch eingebaut und eingerichtet und
natürlich ist die Küche von der Größe
her muss ich sagen eine Küche die so
innen großes Haus passen könnte eine
Familienküche wo man einfach in der
Mitte eine schöne Insel hat im
Hintergrund die E-Geräte dann da hinten
die Armatur ich habe hier ganz bewusst
auch den Herd einfach auf die Rückseite
gepackt damit hier nämlich die Insel
einfach ganz frei ist und man einfach
mal eine Kücheninsel hat sondern
Küchenblock der komplett ohne Störer ist
also ohne irgendwie Steckdosen die
stören und einfach eine schöne Fläche
auf der man arbeiten kann werkeln kann
oder sich im Team eben auch mal
versammeln kann und ich werde jetzt
natürlich erst einmal mein Team dazu
holen denn natürlich habe ich bevor ich
die Küche eingebaut habe auch
nachgefragt was wollt ihr denn alles und
da war natürlich gleich die Frage wir
brauchen eine Mikrowelle die soll mit
eingebaut werden wir brauchen extrem
viel Stauraum viel Platz und vor allem
sollte Küche schön hell und groß sein
das haben wir jetzt schon alles
beherzigt ich zeige euch auch gleich die
küchenpläne aber erst hole ich kurz mein
Team dazu damit wir wissen was Sie hier
alles zubereiten wollen und dann richten
wir die Küche gemeinsam ein
[Musik]
hi guten Morgen
wer von Team die besten Kochkünstler hat
Kochkünste
muss ich kurz mal alle durchgehen
die Natascha macht gut die Macht so
Börek also so ähnlich wie Börek die
macht das in der kompletten Auflaufform
das macht die richtig gut da gibt es
glaube ich mehrere die gute Kochkünste
haben bei uns im Team hätte ich auch
sehr also du zählst definitiv dazu danke
schön die Natascha auf jeden Fall die
kocht auch sehr gerne ich glaube sie
guckt immer dieselben Gerichte aber die
Macht exzellent richtig da ist sie dann
richtig Profi ich würde sagen die
ganz klar
ja stimmen weiß hat das wie man
abschmeckt wie man wird und wenn sie was
macht das schmeckt immer gut aber die
Karo macht auch super
wir haben letztens Spaghetti Bolognese
mit Tofu gegessen gehabt das war's so
lecker Karoline kocht auch glaube ich
gerne sie sagt immer dass sie daheim
immer
ganz gut
die besten Kochkünstler hat natürlich
ich weil den besten Kaffee koche ich
siehst du das als Kochkünste ja
natürlich das heißt ja auch Kaffee
kochen ich würde mich darüber freuen
wenn wir in der Küche
pudelwasser hätten
das ist das für mich ich freue mich
immer wenn ich Sprudel was da irgendwo
bekomme wir würden uns zu der Küche über
Salatbesteck freuen Salatschüssel weil
wir öfters mittags in der Mittagspause
dann und zum Salat machen und wir
frühstücken ja immer Müsli morgens dass
wir da irgendwie aufbewahrungsschalen
oder so haben eine Schublade wo
Süßigkeiten drin sind hör unbedingt
Süßigkeiten für Snacks also ab und zu
Snacks und viele Kaffeetassen weil wir
haben nämlich viele Kaffeetrinker im
Team genau und Tee
natürlich über eine gute Kaffeemaschine
einen guten Kaffee das Thema aufgefüllt
ist wichtig ist dann auch dass wir nach
dem Essen immer sauber machen das ist A
und O weil so kenne ich zwei Sally Sally
die tut alles zubereiten und während sie
das zubereitet tut sie aber auch schon
sauber machen und deswegen brauchen wir
bei uns in der Küche auf jeden Fall auch
ein Ort wo die ganzen Sachen verstaut
werden wo alles ist
um für die Spülmaschine für
den Esstisch zum abputzen allgemein
einfach Schwämme hat das alles an einem
Platz ist damit ihr Wissen da müssen wir
ihn greifen dürfen wir sie dann aber
eine neue Kaffeetasse bringen die bleibt
so
die benutze ich jeden Tag das ist meine
spürst du die ab und zu natürlich
[Musik]
ich zeig mich jetzt mal was mein
Küchenplan war die Küche ist ja etwas
mehr als sechs Meter fünfzig lang und
zwei Meter 70 breit das heißt ich hatte
wirklich ganz viel Platz um die Küche da
größtmöglich einzuplanen und eben auch
viel Stauraum zu schaffen deswegen habe
ich zuallererst die Insel in die Mitte
geplant damit dort das ganze Team immer
schön einen Arbeitsbereich hat der nicht
durch eine Kochstelle gestört wird oder
auch durch andere Objekte die den
Arbeitsbereich eben zerteilen würden das
macht so ein schöner meetingplatz dann
habe ich mir überlegt dass ich links auf
die Seite den Spielplatz mache also den
Wasserplatz nach hinten den Kochplatz
und die Backöfen mit der Mikrowelle und
rechts davon eben Stauraum weiter rechts
habe ich dann noch Platz da geht es
nämlich zum Durchgang zur Terrasse rüber
also ist da Platz für einen richtig
großen Esstisch damit das ganze Team
dort Platz hat an der rechten Seite an
der Wand habe ich eine Pflanzenwand
geplant damit dort Pflanzen und Kräuter
platziert werden können die sowohl in
der Küche als Kräuter dienen als auch
als Dekoration und das ganze ist so eine
Art Verb Element zur Terrasse wo eben
bei schönem Wetter auch draußen gegessen
werden kann
und dann schreibt ihr euch am besten
eure küchenzonen bzw das was ihr
verräumen wollt auf postet und klebt sie
erstmal auf die Außenseite denn so könnt
ihr schon mal vorüberlegen wo alles
hinkommt dann geht es später schneller
und einfacher und vor allem können euch
andere auch mithelfen
[Musik]
habt ihr eigentlich auch viel Süßes und
Snacks
okay
etwas Sally Hits
[Musik]
ich habe hier so einen integrierten
Dunstabzug und deswegen verliere ich da
oben so ein bisschen Platz weil ich da
einfach den Hängeschrank habe zu bauen
lassen müssen aber da ist mir jetzt
eingefallen dass ich diese Fläche hier
einfach nutze für die Organisation das
heißt hier kommen zum Beispiel der
Küchenplan rein Einkaufslisten und es
wird dann später einfach schön beklebt
und kann dann eben auch genutzt werden
gut dann Räume
[Musik]
der Stapel wird nicht weniger wie bei
euch zu Hause wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
wenn ihr viele Teesorten habt und das
Ganze trotzdem übersichtlich bleiben
soll dann könnt ihr den Tee ja hier
quasi öffnen dann sieht man auf dem
Beutel die Beschriftung und dann so in
die Schublade stecken so habe ich den
maximalen Platz und vor allem kommt man
von oben einfach an jede Teesorte dran
ohne dass man im Schrank suchen muss
immer ganz praktisch
[Applaus]
ihr habt auch alle Nationalitäten
muss man jetzt mal schon sagen also
schon Multikulti hier frischer Flirt
mediterraner Pfirsich persischer
Granatapfel ich würde mal sagen hier
geht's mehr ab als in so manchen
Schlafzimmer willkommen in Sallys Welt
in unserer Teeküche
[Musik]
Murat unsere unser Team hatten Tee
Problem
wie du siehst
aber wir sortieren sie nach Regenbogen
und Nationalitäten
ach so ich komme aus dem Garten ich sehe
aus wie ein Schwein ich weiß aber ich
komme aus dem Garten gebraucht
eingezogen
[Musik]
dann geht es hier an den
organisationsschrank da habe ich ja hier
diese weiße Fläche und habe einfach so
eine selbstklebende Magnetfolie besorgt
die Messe ich jetzt ab oder ist sogar
noch Kreide drin
die Messe ich jetzt ab klebt sie hier
rein und dann habe ich noch Stifte dafür
[Musik]
die Schrauben hier habe ich jetzt
einfach ausgelassen habe es kleiner
geschnitten und damit aber trotzdem
schön ist werde ich das jetzt hier
einfach schön mit Tafellack einmal
streichen
[Musik]
hier alles schwarz
mein Team braucht jetzt hier nicht die
Vorräte wie ich also Mehl Zucker
Streusel Kakao backsachen weil sie hier
einfach nicht backen aber sie haben
immer wieder trotzdem offene
Lebensmittel wie zum Beispiel Nudeln
oder Reis weil sie eben nicht immer
komplett in der Verpackung verbrauchen
deswegen mache ich jetzt einen Schrank
mit offenen Lebensmitteln alles schön
verpackt damit alles übersichtlich ist
und nichts kaputt geht und
weggeschmissen wird
[Musik]
für die Müsli Bar das ist salted Karma
das beschrifte ich gleich oh das letzte
was ich gedrückt habe ist
für Eileen
[Musik]
die Farbe ist jetzt getrocknet und jetzt
kann ich hier meine selbstklebende
Magnetfolie dran kleben die Farbe ist
auch magnetisch aber nicht so ganz wie
die Folie deswegen ist die Folie schon
die bessere Wahl und da kommen ihr dann
quasi diese Dinge drauf nämlich
Einkaufsliste und die To-Dos die wir
einlaminiert haben so dass sich das Team
hier schön organisieren kann
[Musik]
ich hätten einfach Maler und Lackierer
bei der Sonne
perfect
[Musik]
und dann könnt ihr mit doppelseitigem
Klebeband das ganze hier drauf kleben
oder natürlich mit Magneten wie Ihr
möchtet
[Musik]
jetzt die Küche hier fertig eingerichtet
und auch fertig dekoriert und ich zeige
sie euch jetzt mal im Detail also hier
vorne haben wir die große Arbeitsfläche
das heißt ich habe hier eine Kücheninsel
die nicht unterbrochen ist durch ein
Kochfeld oder ein Waschbecken das ist
natürlich perfekt weil man gut dran
arbeiten kann aber wenn sich zum
Beispiel das Team auch mal
zusammensetzen möchte und was besprechen
möchte haben Sie hier einfach eine große
Fläche außerdem ist es perfekt denn hier
haben wir die Möglichkeit auch mal ein
Buffet zum Beispiel aufzubauen werden
wir zum Beispiel Pizza für alle
bestellen oder wie hier gemeinsam was
zubereiten dann ist hier einfach
ausreichend Platz hier vorne habe ich ja
diese schönen holzauszüge und was hier
ganz oben drin verstaut ist ist
sozusagen die organisationsschublade da
haben wir zum Beispiel Flyer drin zum
Essen bestellen aber auch Servietten und
was hier auch ganz wichtig ist einfach
Verbandszeug und Pflaster was man eben
so in der Küche braucht und dann habe
ich natürlich auch Schublade und
Schränke die noch gar nicht befüllt sind
so wie hier unten zum Beispiel damit das
Team eben auch noch was dazu nehmen kann
und einfach Platz hat um andere Dinge zu
verstauen als die die ich jetzt hier
besorgt habe dann habe ich hier vorne
die zwei großen Auszüge und das könnt
ihr bei der Küchenplanung auch immer so
machen wenn ihr nämlich möchtet dass das
Ganze vorne schön sauber aussieht aber
innen quasi eine Unterteilung sein soll
könnt ihr die großen Fronten machen und
ihnen quasi die Innenauszüge und hier
haben wir zum Beispiel im einen Schrank
einfach einen Korb für
Pfand so kann man das immer leicht
rausnehmen und freitags einfach schön
wegbringen und einen Korb links der ist
dann für Glas
und hier natürlich ganz wichtig
der ganze Süßigkeit Vorrat der ist hier
vorne
[Musik]
dann habe ich hier in der Küche den
Wasserplatz wo alles gereinigt wird und
hier haben wir das jetzt ganz toll
gelöst ich habe hier nämlich die
Spülmaschine erhöht so dass das Team
sich einfach nicht so oft bücken muss
denn alles was man auf ergonomischer
Höhe planen kann sollte man wirklich
auch tun und einfach das ganze Rücken
schonend gestalten deswegen ist hier die
Spülmaschine hier das Spülbecken den
Müll habe ich einmal hier drunter und
weil wir hier natürlich eine recht
aufwendige mülteilung haben habe ich
auch einen Teil des Münster drüben und
alles was man quasi für die Spülmaschine
braucht befindet sich hier und da das
heißt hier habe ich einen Schrank
eingeplant mit dem kesse immer runter
das heißt hier hat man quasi alles was
für den täglichen Bedarf ist zum
Beispiel
Spülmaschinenpulver schön verpackt
Philipp schau dir das an da waren früher
deine Süßigkeiten drin jetzt ist unser
Spülmaschinenpulver drin denn ich muss
auch sagen vielleicht auch als Tipp für
euch zu Hause wir verwenden immer das
klassikpulver Plus spülmaschinensalz und
Spülmaschinen Klarspüler denn die
Spülmaschine dosiert das ganze von
alleine das heißt ihr könnt euch da
immer diese sparen wo quasi alles in
einem ist weil die Spülmaschine einfach
besser weiß wie viel Salz und wie viel
fleischspüler sie braucht und das ganze
spart dann auch noch extrem viel Geld
weil das Pulver eigentlich so das
günstigste ist was man bekommt dann habe
ich hier noch Essig und die ganzen
Reinigungsmittel und zum Beispiel
Küchenpapier Küchenrolle auf Vorrat den
man eben auch so täglich braucht und was
hier am Dell ganz gut ist ihr könnt hier
alles schön verstauen und eben schön
drehen dann sieht man was eben drin ist
und alles was man braucht hat man dann
eben griffbereit und was man nicht
täglich braucht sind die ganzen Vorräte
wie zum Beispiel Essigessenz auf Vorrat
Spülmittel die ganzen Schwämme oder eben
auch Klarspüler und Spezialsalz und da
muss man nicht so häufig dran deswegen
kann das Ganze eher weiter oben gelagert
werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann habe ich mich hier für ein schönes
schwarzes Spülbecken von Blanco
entschieden da haben wir die Armatur und
damit hier jeder quasi auch
Leitungswasser trinken kann gekühltes
gefiltertes Sprudel Medium oder still
haben wir hier quasi die blanko Soda
eingebaut und da kann man wirklich hin
und sich zum Beispiel hier oben ein Glas
nehmen
kann auswählen zwischen sprudelstil oder
Medium ich mache jetzt mal 300
Milliliter und zack und da hat man es
direkt gekühlt auf dem Wasser
und so sparen wir uns das ganze Leergut
wir sparen uns die ganzen
wasserbestellungen die Wasserkästen und
haben einfach immer schönes kaltes
Wasser es muss nicht im Kühlschrank
gelagert werden und man sieht auch
direkt immer wie viel man trinkt und
deswegen habe ich auch hier neben dran
auch zum Beispiel diese Glaskaraffe da
kann man sich was abfüllen mit so einem
Platten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann habe ich hier noch die ganzen
Küchentücher quasi zum Putzen zum
Abtrocknen und was hier auch ganz cool
ist weil ich einfach hier den Platz auch
hatte hier hat man quasi zwei Stangen wo
man eben auch die feuchten Tücher
einfach schön drüber hängen kann dann
zeige ich euch noch den Inhalt der
Vitrinenschränke und ich finde so
Vitrinenschränke das hört sich immer ein
bisschen oldschool altmodisch an aber
ich finde in so einer Küche wie hier
lokplatz das ganze so ein bisschen auf
weil eben nicht alles zu ist aber
trotzdem schön verschlossen hinter einem
Milchglas wo man eben den Inhalt nicht
so gut sieht das heißt muss auch nicht
immer so perfekt aufgeräumt sein oder es
kann auch mal Stau gut sein was nicht so
schön ist aber man hat trotzdem so ein
bisschen den Durchblick ich haben wir
das ganze einfach mit Touch quasi also
man öffnet das ganze per Touch und hat
hier quasi den Drücker wo der ganze
Schrank wieder zugeht ist eben auch
praktisch für Menschen die nicht so groß
sind und hier oben an den Schrank eben
nicht mehr kommen könnten und hier haben
wir so die Tee Abteilung also Murat und
seiner Gäste da unten die ganzen
Schüsseln die man braucht für Snacks für
Müsli oder auch eben auch so mal für
eine kleine Schüssel da habe ich ganz
viele Trinkgläser und hier hinten bei
der Kaffeemaschine eben die Kaffeetassen
die Espressotassen und eben auch den
Kaffee Vorrat zum auffüllen
[Musik]
ich habe mich nur Schublade mit Deckeln
und Abdeckungen wie zum Beispiel die
flexdeckel die man auf jede Schüssel
stellen und legen kann und sie dann eben
verschließt so brauchen wir keine
Alufolie und keine Frischhaltefolie und
haben alles eben schön nachhaltig
genauso die stretchies die man über
alles was offen ist drüber stülpen kann
und das befindet sich alles hier hier
unten habe ich einen Eckschrank der ist
nämlich geht hier quasi um die ganze
Ecke und hier habe ich den Le Mans mit
eingebaut von kesselwürmer da kann man
nämlich den kompletten Schrank Inhalt
einfach rausziehen kann hier große
Gegenstände lagern wie zum Beispiel
Salatschüsseln oder große Rührschüssel
die mein Team eben auch hier braucht um
vieles Salate zuzubereiten und dann kann
man das einfach hier wieder weg
verstauen
[Musik]
hier ist die Kaffee und Müsli war also
wie gesagt Kaffeemaschine hier Kaffee
Vorrat zum Auffüllen da oben hier haben
wir alles was so für das tägliche
müslitter ist ich habe hier einfach
richtig schöne müslispender die ich auch
schon bei kitchen eins verwendet habe da
kann man nämlich einfach hin mit der
müsli-schale die befindet sich nämlich
direkt hier und kann sich dann das Müsli
zusammensuchen und einfach schön
portionieren und hier hat man also alles
was man sozusagen braucht ich wollte
schon wieder quasi sagen ich habe heute
echt schon richtig oft quasi gesagt aber
ist egal davon wollen wir uns nicht
beirren lassen dann habe ich hier noch
cookido funch was eben auch sehr gut zum
Müsli passt und Zucker was man so bei
der Kaffeemaschine braucht und diese
zwei oder drei Schubladen hier sind die
vorbereitungsschubladen das heißt alles
dass man zum Beispiel zum Gemüse
Lebensmittel vorbereiten braucht
befindet sich hier Schneidebretter ich
habe ich aber auch alles was noch zu
Kaffeemaschine gehört also Kaffeezubehör
und da ist einfach immer wichtig alles
da zu verstauen wo man es eben am Ende
auch braucht hier habe ich die ganzen
Messbecher und die kleinen Schälchen für
suppensalate für Lebensmittel die man
eben verarbeitet und hier oben mit dem
schönen Holzeinsatz schön sortiert eben
das ganze Besteck das ist hier damit
hier jeder dran kommt hier braucht man
Besteck für Müsli für Kaffee aber eben
auch zum Essen und ich habe es
absichtlich nicht hier oder da vorne
verstaut damit man eben nicht davor
steht weil hier eben keine
Arbeitsstation ist sondern nur eine
Station wo man Dinge abholt und so stört
man andere Teammitglieder nicht die
vielleicht gerade am Kochen sind oder
hier am schneiden sind oder am rühren
und hat hier alles schön griffbereit
genau die ganzen Messer habe ich noch
hier und eben auch sowas wie die ganzen
reiben was man eben so benötigt
was ich hier auch richtig schön finde da
habe ich einfach von Nobilia diese
Holzplatten genommen und habe diese
Abteilungen reingesteckt die man dann
eben gut verwenden kann und da gibt es
verschiedene Systeme aber ich finde
tatsächlich die am besten denn es hat
Systeme von anderen Küchenherstellern
die man unten verschrauben muss und dann
ist man eben nicht mehr so flexibel wenn
man das Innenleben doch wieder umräumt
so wie ich ganz oft und hier hat man
sozusagen einfach die Möglichkeit die
Holz Steckteile reinzustecken dann doch
wieder wegzunehmen woanders hinzustecken
und dann passt es eben ganz gut und was
ich hier unten in der Schublade dann
noch habe das sind die ganzen Vorräte
für die Abteilung hier also Müsli
Vorräte Kaffee oder auch heiße
Schokolade und Tee und da muss man eben
nicht so oft dran deswegen ist es hier
ganz weit unten
[Musik]
hier sind wir in der küchenzone kochen
denn hier ist meine Kochplatte die ist
am in die Arbeitsplatte integriert und
einfach flächenbündig so kann man sie
sehr gut sauber halten und alles ist
immer schön ordentlich hier habe ich die
Hochschränke und die gehen so auf das
heißt nach oben die zwei äußeren hier
ist ja der Dunstabzug der hier schön
versteckt ist einfach flach und hier
habe ich auch den Vorteil dass ich
keinen Dunstabzug im Kochfeld drin habe
ich habe dann einen ein Kochfeld was
eben nicht ganz so groß ist und trotzdem
aber die volle Größe ausnutzen kann weil
eben der Dunstabzug hier einfach an der
Wand ist hier dahinter habe ich ja die
organisationswand mit der Magnettafel wo
man eben die Einkaufsliste schön hat das
to-do also die To-Do-Listen oder eben
auch der Küchendienst wo man alles
magnetisch verstauen kann und was ich
auch immer ganz gut finde falls ihr so
einen Schrank habt der eben vom Platz
her nicht so viel hergibt dann nutzt ihn
doch auch als organisationsschrank also
packt da alle Fernbedienungen mit rein
alle Stifte mit rein
Notizzettel das könnt ihr alles hier
schön verstauen und habt eben
übersichtlich hier rechts und links habe
ich Lebensmittel wie zum Beispiel
Gewürze oder auch die ganzen saucenöle
und Essig was man ebenso für den
täglichen Gebrauch da haben sollte und
damit auch wirklich jeder an das
Innenleben des Schranks dann kommt und
nicht jeder 180 groß ist habe ich hier
auf beiden Seiten den einmove eingebaut
so kann man den ganzen Schrank Inhalt
nach unten ziehen kann ihn auch gerne
eine Zeit lang stehen lassen wenn man
hier gerade am Kochen ist und eben
Zutaten und Gewürze braucht und später
dann eben auch ganz einfach mit einer
Handbewegung wieder oben verschwinden
lassen so hat man es übersichtlich
ordentlich und es gibt keine
Lebensmittel die man oben irgendwo in
der Ecke vergisst und das ist ja auch
gerade ganz wichtig wenn man eben mit
vielen Menschen in der Küche arbeitet
[Musik]
dann habe ich hier noch ganz viele
Schubladen viel Stauraum hier habe ich
zum Beispiel die kochhelfer aus Silikon
die alle einen edelstahlkern haben alle
von kochblume muss ich sagen und damit
sind wir auch seit vielen vielen Jahren
richtig zufrieden weil sie hygienisch
sind sauber sind lebensmittelecht man
kann sie in die Spülmaschine packen sie
zerkratzen keine Töpfe und Pfannen und
sind einfach Hitze fest das heißt auch
wenn ihr mal was frittiert was jetzt
hier zwar wahrscheinlich niemand macht
aber wenn ihr mal was frittiert könnt
ihr die auch benutzen und die habe ich
hier alle schön alles was man sozusagen
hier braucht beim Kochen und Backen und
alles was man zum Servieren braucht habe
ich hier hinten an der Küchentheke hier
habe ich auch noch die Schublade für
mein Team weil mein Team ja Teetrinker
ist und hier sind jetzt alle Teesorten
schön übersichtlich nach
Regenbogenfarben sortiert unser kommt
jeder von oben schön dran und es ist für
jeden auf jeden Fall auch was dabei hier
unten habe ich eine Schublade mit
Aufbewahrungsdosen da kann man einfach
übrig geblieben ist eben schön im
Kühlschrank verstauen oder auch in
anderen einschränken und wie gesagt habe
ich nicht alles voll gepackt denn mein
Team wird mit Sicherheit in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen einfach auch noch
stauguthaben zum Verstauen hier auf der
Kücheninsel ihr fragt euch jetzt
bestimmt wo die ganzen Töpfe und Pfannen
sind aber ich finde es immer gut wenn
man hier steht und kocht und nicht
direkt darunter die Töpfe und Pfannen
hat weil dann wenn jemand anderes noch
dazu kommt muss man immer von vom Herd
sozusagen weggehen das heißt ich habe
ich auch nur einen ganz kleinen Weg zur
Arbeitsplatte und habe hier auch wieder
auf ergonomischer Höhe einfach die Töpfe
und Pfannen schön einsortiert dann gibt
es hier eine Schublade mit Besteck was
man zum Servieren braucht also
Salatbesteck oder auch das Holz Besteck
oder die Elli zum Beispiel die brauche
auf jeden Fall asiatisches Besteck hatte
sich gewünscht dass sie hier ihre
Stäbchen verstauen kann und alle
Gegenstände wie Zitruspresse
Knoblauchpresse servier Paletten oder
auch bienenwachstücher zum Verpacken von
Lebensmitteln sind eben auch hier
dann habe ich hier auf der Seite den
Kühlschrank der ist auch schön versteckt
und da ist Platz für alle wir haben
einen eingebauten Kühlschrank ausgewählt
mit vitafrash Fächern für viel Obst und
Gemüse aber auch für viel Platz wenn man
eben was mitbringt oben ein kleines
Gefrierfach und darüber eben noch ein
bisschen Stauraum
[Musik]
was ich hier auch mit eingebaut habe
weil es einfach sehr robust ist und ich
die Arbeitsplatten liebe das sind ja die
Straße Arbeitsplatten und die habe ich
hier in der Lederoptik das heißt die ist
matt die ist nicht poliert und ist eine
richtig schöne helle Arbeitsplatte die
sehr robust ist das heißt sie ist nicht
hitzeempfindlich man kann da heiße Töpfe
Pfannen und auch Backbleche abstellen
man könnte sogar drauf schneiden wobei
ich das nie empfehle weil ihr dann eure
Messer eben auch kaputt macht und sie
ist eben kratzfest und immer schön und
es ist wirklich ein Arbeitsplatte die
ich auch drüben bei mir in den Küchen
schon seit vier Jahren verbaut habe da
passiert echt nichts also da hat man
wirklich eine Arbeitsplatte die überlebt
euch also die überlebt wirklich alles
weil sie einfach sehr schön und sehr
robust ist und ich finde hier passte
perfekt rein so das schilfgrün mit der
schönen hellen Platte ich finde es hat
einfach so so ein Look von dem schönen
Sommerhaus
ich habe den Backofen und die Mikrowelle
eine Mikrowelle natürlich damit man sich
mitgebracht das Essen schön und schnell
warm machen kann der Backofen ist das
exklusiv Gerät was es bei Nobilia gibt
nämlich der Bosch Backofen der hat zum
einen der Pyrolyse was hier ganz wichtig
ist falls doch mal was daneben geht dann
kann man nämlich mit der
pyrolysefunktion den Backofen reinigen
bzw der reinigt sich von ganz alleine
indem man sich auf über 480 Grad
hochheizt dann alle Lebensmittelreste
verbrennt sogar Fett und am Ende muss
man es nur noch so ein bisschen
ausreiben also quasi die Asche die übrig
bleibt ihr habt hier die Funktion dass
man Autopilot verwenden kann das
bedeutet dass man das Gargut reinstellt
also das essen was man zubereiten möchte
und der Backofen stellt von ganz alleine
die Heizart die Temperatur und die Zeit
ein so dass das Essen gar wird und
wirklich auch perfekt gar wird und
schaltet sich nach dem Garvorgang
einfach automatisch von alleine aus und
der Backofen ist home Connect fähig das
heißt ihr könnt ihn einfach mit eurer
home Connect App oder zum Beispiel mit
der Sallys Welt App connecten könnt da
aus über 1500 Rezepten empfehlen und
dann eben das Rezept zubereiten hier in
der Küche und ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
darum kümmern wie der Backofen
eingestellt wird ihr sendet quasi aus
dem Rezept heraus die Einstellungen
direkt an den Backofen und der erledigt
alles von ganz alleine das finde ich
natürlich immer sehr praktisch hier oben
habe ich dann noch zum Backblech
verstauen einfach einen schönen Schrank
ich habe hier Backbleche Pizzableche und
ofenformen und die haben einfach alle
schön Platz und mehr wird hier
tatsächlich auch gar nicht benötigt und
dann haben wir hier zuletzt noch einen
Schrank das ist der Vorratsschrank aber
eben auch der Geschirrschrank weil hier
gleich auch der Esstisch steht und hier
habe ich auf dieser Höhe einfach das
Geschirr weil es Geschirr doch recht
schwer ist und man so ganz gut rankommt
und wirklich alles schön übersichtlich
hat da oben dann einfach noch Vorräte
die hier oft benutzt werden wie Olivenöl
Tomatensoße und so weiter oder auch
Nudeln und Reis und weiter unten Vorräte
die eben auch oft gebraucht werden wie
Milch und Hafermilch oder eben auch
Linsen und Reis
und weil ich sehr schön finde und auch
praktisch haben wir da vorne noch das
stollenregal von Nobilia wonach viele
von euch fragen und das ist ein
Regalsystem was es eben in dieser großen
Länge gibt aber das gibt es auch nur
halbhoch was man eben auf die
Arbeitsfläche auch integrieren kann und
dann in die Küche mit einbauen kann ihr
habt hier zum Beispiel wachstumslichter
das sieht man hier ganz gut für die
Küchenkräuter und für uns ist er der
Garten ganz wichtig Balkon Terrasse weil
für uns ja auch raspberry ganz wichtig
ist das heißt alles was die Natur
betrifft was pflanzenbäume Gärtnern
findet ja draußen statt aber eben auch
drinnen und deswegen habe ich hier mit
dem stollenregal so die Verbindung von
der Küche zur Terrasse geschaffen und
habe hier eben auch ganz viel von
raspberry eben auch platziert wie zum
Beispiel die Pflanzenmittel die man eben
draußen verwendet aber auch drinnen und
ich habe hier einfach so eine Mischung
aus allem gemacht das heißt es ist
dekorativ aber auch funktional mit allem
was man so in der Küche eben auch
braucht
[Musik]
und wo wir gerade bei den schönen Dingen
sind wir haben natürlich lange überlegt
was bei einem Esstisch wir hier in die
Küche integrieren wollen und ihr wisst
ja Murat das immer sehr innovativ und
der interpretiert ja auch immer seine
viaplatten ganz neu und dann hat er sich
mit dem Eugen mit seinem Tischler des
Vertrauens zusammengesetzt und sie haben
hier diesen Tisch gemeinsam entwickelt
das heißt eine Holzkonstruktion gebaut
mit Metallfüßen und darauf haben Sie
dann diese Fliesen diese viaplatten
verlegt was ich richtig schön finde vor
allem passen sie optisch farblich
einfach perfekt in die Küche der Tisch
ist lang genug für das ganze Team oder
für ein Teil des Teams die dann immer
mal versetzt Mittagessen können und es
ist einfach schön es schafft ein ganz
neues Ambiente hier in und vor allem ist
es ein ganz individueller Tisch weil der
wirklich jetzt nur hier für uns
existiert und ich weiß dass Murat und
Eugen die Tische auch so anfertigen
unten haben wir noch einen anderen Tisch
und ich meine das mal beim Eugen die
Tische Auto stellen kann
aber das ist der schöne Tischdecke hat
hier rein der ist richtig schön und ich
habe dann hier einfach auf dem Tisch so
ein großes Tablett stehen mit
Gewürzmühlen Obst frisches Obst fürs
ganze Team und ich finde es einfach
richtig schön ist eine richtig schöne
gemütliche Küche geworden
[Musik]
ich muss sagen mir gefällt die Küche
richtig gut das ist sogar die Küche muss
ich sagen die mir momentan am besten
gefällt also am liebsten wäre es mir ich
würde jeden Morgen und jeden Mittag und
Abend drin verbringen können weil ich
einfach dieses schilfgrün mit der
Landhausküche richtig schön finde und
sie trotzdem aber nicht so altbacken
aussieht weil man Landhaus eben auch
ganz toll modern kombinieren kann und
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und dass ihr euch wieder
ein paar Tipps und Tricks zum Küche
planen einräumen einrichten oder auch
zum Küche dekorieren mitnehmen konntet
und ich würde mich natürlich ganz ganz
arg freuen wenn ihr euer Feedback
hinterlasst das heißt schreibt doch mal
ganz gerne ob das so eine Küche wärt ihr
euch gut gefällt ob euch das Video
hilfreich genug war und dann werden wir
nämlich das nächste Mal die Küche unten
gemeinsam einräumen und ich zeige euch
unten die Küche wie ich die geplant habe
wie sie dekoriert wird und wie sie
eingeräumt wird und dann kommt ja schon
ganz bald auch die Community Küche denn
die Community Küche wurde jetzt
ausgelost es ist ein ich verrate
eigentlich noch nicht so viel das
Pärchen weiß sozusagen noch gar nicht
dass sie ausgewählt wurden denn sie
werden vor Ort überrascht und ich bin
selbst schon sehr gespannt darauf wie
Sie darauf reagieren werden denn sie
wollen die Küche verschenken an jemand
anderes ganz lieben deswegen bleibt
gespannt bleibt dran und wir sehen uns
wieder beim nächsten Mal tschüss eure
Küche ist fertig ihr könnt sie jetzt
benutzen
[Musik]
ihr wisst schon dass wir 9 Uhr morgens
haben und ihr fragt mich daran zur Küche
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe ein neues Trinkspiel Leute
jedes Mal wenn sie quasi sagt trinken
wir eigentlich so
Ella komm wir drehen jetzt eine Werbung
[Musik]
danke schön
brauche ich noch mal Lippenstift
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und dann gibt es natürlich auch
Schublade und Schränke die einfach nicht
voll geplant
voll bepackt sind voll gepackt mit
tollen Sachen die das Leben schöner
machen so ja okay
ich kann das nicht
jetzt habe ich eine komplette Küche
könnt ihr das bitte in die Liste
eintragen Dinge die ich nicht kann
abrubbeln Punkt
[Musik]
und hier hat man also alles was man
sozusagen braucht ich wollte schon
wieder quasi sagen ich habe halt echt
schon richtig oft quasi gesagt aber ist
egal davon wollen wir uns nicht mehr
irren lassen hier sind wir in der
küchenzone kochen denn hier ist quasi
ich will hier einfach so eine Wohnung
einrichten so hier ist die Küche
Esszimmer da können wir da hinten
Wohnzimmer
Karaoke Ecke mit Bar hinten schlafen
Dusche ja passt Büro oder wollte ich
schon eine luftwohnung
zum Download bereit kostenlos
Werbung Produktplatzierung
[Musik]